in diesen heißen tagen wird der berliner
feuerwehr ausgerechnet das trinkwasser
rationiert unglaubliche geschichte die
feuerwehrleute von berlin menschen das
ist ja eine truppe die einen der
härtesten jobs macht den zielen
deutschland überhaupt so gibt sie
erinnern sich gerade erst im so
komplizierten einsatz bei dem großbrand
im munitionslager im berliner grunewald
da waren die feuerwehrleute aber dieser
irren hitze wirklich bis zur absoluten
erschöpfung im einsatz
jetzt kommt der hammer die politik hier
in berlin gekürzt genau diesen feuerwehr
helden jetzt das trinkwasser das ist
wirklich eine unglaubliche story
normalerweise kriegt jede wache
reichlich mineralwasser na klar zum
durst löschen in den schweißtreibenden
einsetzen aber dieses trinkwasser das
wird jetzt rationiert begründung kein
geld mehr da hier sieht man dass kein
geld für wasser mehr da steht in roth
unter die berliner feuerwehr helden den
berlin jetzt nicht mal mehr wasser
bezahlen will zum trinken darüber
sprechen wir mit manuel bartsch vom
berliner landesverband der deutschen
feuerwehr gewerkschaft größe herzlicher
bad wie stark fühlen sie sich da gewerk
schätzt gewertschätzt als feuerwehrmann
ja also ich denke mal zur klarheit
gehört jetzt natürlich auch zu sagen was
es denn wirklich passiert und was liegt
da jetzt wirklich schon es ist so dass
die haushaltstitel für diesen bedarf an
einsatzstellen wasser er seit jahren
nicht so genehmigt wird wie er beantragt
wird also in diesem jahr ist es so dass
es gerade mal ein drittel des bedarfs
genehmigt wurde als das was die berliner
feuerwehr beantragt man muss auch dazu
sagen dass dennoch die führungs dienste
also die einsätze dann einsetzt wenn die
möglichkeit haben auch unabhängig des
erschöpften haushaltstitel auf einkäufe
und auf mineralwasser zurückzugreifen
also was ich damit sagen bild ist es
wird da nichts gratuliert ist es auch
nicht wirklich der hahn abgedreht
sondern wir haben letztendlich wieder
ein budget problem was aber schon seit
jahren intern durch die feuerwehr
verstärkten ausgeglichen wird also ein
nicht ganz neues problem was aber schön
ist an der stelle oftmals ist es ja so
dass was schlecht ist auch was gutes zu
beleuchten wie den allgemeinen die
einsatzstellen versorgung organisiert
und auch und genau darum geht es ja herr
barth sie sagen jetzt wird nicht
rationiert ist ja völlig klar da wird
niemand verdursten im einsatz das ist
klar es geht um wertschätzung in dieser
frage um die ausstellung derer die halt
jeden tag einen harten job machen
deswegen auch meine frage wie sehr
fühlen sie sich da als feuerwehrmann
gewertschätzt das ist eine frage von
respekt der die wertschätzung also wer
aufmerksam die medien den letzten wochen
beobachtet hat es ist schon schwierig
und selbst die personalversammlung ging
durch die bietet die wertschätzung bzw
die die kollegen sind sind dadurch also
der vertrauensverlust der in den langen
vergangenen monaten und jahren stattfand
er muss erst wieder aufgebaut werden die
das gefühl der wertschätzung im
allgemeinen ist kaum noch spürbar
in cannes als seien wir sehen wie sehr
die kolleginnen und kollegen im einsatz
sind während den großbrand ja jetzt in
den letzten tagen erwähnt wo tag und
nacht durchgearbeitet wurde und sie
sagen jetzt abgesehen von mineralwasser
das ist ein punkt den wir uns
herausgenommen haben bei dem ehrlich
gesagt bei uns die alarmglocken los ging
war ich finde das gehört zum
grundsätzlichen dass man schaut dass die
kollegen gut ausgestattet sind dass wir
alles haben um diesen knochenjob leisten
zu können jetzt sind sie hier heute bei
uns und sagen auch die wertschätzung
wenn sie mir mit der wertschätzung aus
der glauben die kolleginnen und kollegen
eher schon gar nicht mehr dran
ja genau also wie gesagt dafür ist in
der vergangenheit zu viel passiert dafür
gab es viel zu viele versprechungen und
auf der einen seite aber letztendlich
dann das fehlende durchhalten an der
anderen seite und ja alleine wie gesagt
bei dem haushaltstitel wenn wir davon
sprechen dass nur also eher bedarf wurde
erkannt wie viel man braucht um
wenigstens einsatzstellen was hat damit
die kollegen auf deutsch gesagt nicht
aus der pfütze laufen müssen um da einen
sind einsatzstellen wasser rann zu
kriegen wenn sie dann nur ein drittel
bekommen weil es heißt wir müssen sparen
dann ist es sicherlich die die falsche
ecke wie an so vielen falschen die feier
wird und immer nur gesehen wenn sie dann
just in dem moment gebraucht wird wenn
sie mal eine stunde nichts zu tun hat
wird es dann gerne die sitzen nur um und
da an diesem image dann müssen wir
vielleicht auch seitens der politik ein
bisschen arbeiten dass es
eben genau darum geht die feuerwehr
vorzuhalten und dementsprechend aus zu
listen mit allen möglichen was es
braucht und auch beim grunewald haben ja
gesehen dass es mit der einsatzstellen
verpflegung da ging es ja dann auch
nicht nur im wasser sondern auch um
etwas zu essen also man kann ja nicht
erst nach dem halben tag feststellen
dass da menschen arbeiten die natürlich
auch mal was zu essen brauchen dort
stundenlang beschäftigt sind und die
organisation an der stelle
es kann ich eben ganz konkret nicht
sagen was ich weiß was ich gehört habe
ist dass es am falschen standort erst
mal angefahren wurde und dass dieser
immer vorne direkt an der an der spitze
im grunde nicht in den genuss gekommen
sind und deswegen weniger von
einsatzorganisationen da gibt es am
haushaltstitel dieses jahr tatsächlich
auch entsprechend dass fahrzeuge die
sogar genehmigt wurden muss man ganz
klar sein hallo herr barth weil uns
wurde immer gesagt bei den ganzen presse
statement alles super läuft ja alles 1a
bei dem einsatz das heißt die die da bis
zur erschöpfung bis in die nacht rein
und unter großer gefährdung im einsatz
waren im grunewald hier hatten erst mal
nichts zu essen sie hatten eine zeitlang
im rundfunk eine zusatzversorgung zusatz
verfliegen und einsetzen es ist richtig
das ist auch seitens der feuerwehr
durchaus aufgenommen und auch mitgeteilt
wurde aber wie gesagt das sind halt
immer wieder diese kleinigkeiten die das
vertrauen dann schmälern und sie
sprachen das an die wertschätzung finde
ich auch keine kleinigkeit bei 35 grad
zu schuften unter nicht mal was über
essen zu kriegen da bleiben wir dran an
dem thema herr barth vielen herzlichen
dank ihnen für die der information ich
danke ihnen machen
[Musik]